Google Slides lets you
collaborate with others
to create presentations
that engage your audience,
whether you're using the
web, Android, or iOS.
Typically, the most
effective presentations
use data to help tell stories.
But sometimes, it's hard to
import data from other sources
without considerable
manual work.
That's why we're
building a Slides API.
We want to make it
easier to establish
connections between slides and
the tools you use every day.
Let's take a look at
how two of our partners
are using the Slides API.
First up is SalesforceIQ,
a small business CRM tool.
Now, every sales manager knows
the pain of preparing reports
before a meeting.
They have to
collect the numbers,
build the reports, name, copy,
paste, resize, and, of course,
brand it, which represents a
daunting amount of manual work.
The new integration between
Slides and SalesforceIQ
makes this a simple operation.
For example, to create a
presentation-ready report,
click Create Google Slide
Presentation on your Reports
tab in SalesforceIQ.
Select the reports that
will go into your deck,
a date range, and
you're all set.
Your data and charts will appear
formatted and ready to present.
It can also be shared with
others who may not have access
to SalesforceIQ.
The new API makes
it easy for partners
to export data from other tools
and leverage functionality
and slides to create great
looking visual reports.
Second is Conga, a
tool that makes it easy
for you to use Salesforce
data in other applications.
Conga recognized that their
users require the flexibility
to collaborate with
others to develop
polished materials with a
consistent look and feel.
Users can define customizable
presentation templates
to perform common tasks.
As a result of a Conga
integration with Slides,
they can merge, transform,
and stylize Salesforce data,
charts, and images into a
presentable Google Slides
presentation.
This saves them
considerable time,
while removing copy and paste
errors from the process.
The new Slides API can
be used to empower users
to merge data from
other products
into Slides to create custom
presentations quickly.
These integrations, along with
those from our other partners,
will be launching with our
API in the coming months.
Visit
developers.google.com/slides
for more details.
We look forward to
seeing what you create.